الامير هاري وزوجته ميجان ميركل سيطردان
من منزلهما الريفي
رغم انفاقهما الملايين على ترميمه فهل
سيستردان بعض هذه الاموال الخبراء يقولون
في احلامهما
رك او منزل فروج مور الريفي يقع على اراضي
قلعه غربيه لندن وكان من المفترض ان يكون
مقر اقامه هاري وميجان الرسمي في بريطانيا
قبل ان يتخلى عن لقبهما الملكي
المقر المكون من 10 غرف نوم كان هديه
الملك الراحله اليزابيث
بعد حفل زفافهما عام 2018
لينتقل اليه الزوجان لفتره محدوده عقب
ولاده طفلهما الاول
وسرعان ما ذهب للعيش في ولايه كاليفورنيا
بعد تحررهما من قيود الملكيه في عام 2020
املا في بناء حياه ومهن جديده
ودعى العرش ومعه فروج موركوتيج وكذلك
ملايين الدولارات لم يستخدم الزوجان مقر
اقامتهما في فروغمور خلال مكوثهما في
امريكا الا في مناسبات قليله ورغم انهما
انفقا ثلاثه ملايين ومائه الف دولار على
تجديده وترميمه الا انهما معرضان للطرد
وعدم استرداد تلك المبالغ
يبدو ان هذا سيكون ثمنا باهضا مقابل
اصرارهما على حياه طبيعيه
جرد الملك تشارلز الثالث ابنه الامير هاري
وزوجته ميجا ماركل من فروج مور كوتيج في
الحادي عشر من يناير بعد يوم من نشر هاري
مذكراته المثيره للجدل
التي انتقد خلالها افرد العائله الملكيه